TO MAR-A-LAGO.ENT AFTERWERE CLAS
E'PRARESNS ABOUT THEHITE
INCLUDING TRUMP RIPPING UP MENTG
WARNED NOT TO.SSUTNT.
AND JE THI
ULTIPLE LETTERS
ED FROM THE ARCHIVES, SO
TELLE  NING TON
THCHESN r: THESE LETTERS S
CONCERNED FOR YEARS TRITHO
ITOTPHYSICALALES MEDIA ACCOUWE'
THAT THE ARCHIVES WARNED
WHITHOUSE COUNCIL'S OFFICE
BACK IN 2018 THAT TRUMP'S
PAPERS, AS HE WAO,
WAS A
PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS ACT.AT WAR
DOCUMENTTE CHIVES REIV
OFFICE, THEY'RE NOW SAYI
PAPERS SOME OF THEM  STILL
OTHERS HAD ACTUALLY BEENED
BACK TOGETHER.
RCHIVEISNG THIS O RAISNCERNS
ERINTHE
STAFA PRESENCEE  KDELETEEEW
THE ARCHIVES DOESN'T HAVSS RDS.
AND THEY'RE SAYING A LOT OF
OFFICIAL BUSINESS MIGHT HAVE TU
ARCHIVES JUST DOESN'T
HAVE THE ROR
W THI ACONCERNS FROM THE ARCHI
EREY'RE NOW
AS ATIONS HERE.
WHAT SHE CALLSDISREGARD FOR FED
AND  Y
CLASSIFIED MATERIAL THAT WAS
FOUND AT
DISCUSSED WITH THE JCE NTREEXPEE
CO T
DISCUSSED WITH THE DOJ, SO HAPP?
AANK YOU VERY
MUCH, JESSICA.
SHANU ERED D INFTIR-A-LAO
PROSUT TTORNEY GENERALANW U' ARE
INRM TSETRUMP TOOKO MAR-A-LAGO
E CONVERSATIONS
YOU?
>>ELL, TGNAL TO ME THE NG
JOB, AND NOW THE QUESTION ISLL
DISTINGUISH FOR OUR VIEWERE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN OPENING VE L
INVEST I
DERELIN Y NOTO
INVESTIGATE THIS BECAUSE IT'S
SUCH AN OBVIOUS POTENTIAVIOLATM
NTS THE FROMHE
HIGHEST
TOUMP IS AWARE TSE SHOULR  LEFT.
WE
SOME OF THE BOXES.
HE VNDETM KIM
JOTHERE.
AL IS IN THERE  TO US, OF
SO WHAT COULD HAPPEN TP REHEN T
SO QUESTIONS TO DERMULD HAPPEN
HIM REALLY DEPENDSN THINGS
TS
THOSE DOCUMENTS THAT SP CLSIHE
SUCH?
BEISSUES GO TO WHAT
E
THEM.AY HAVEE F NTD DECLASSIFYI
BECAUSE AT
TOIN WHICH I GET
CLASSIFY, DECLASSIFY AND
O BE ITAO
IF ALL THAT LOOK
IN THE TABLE SUPPOSED TO BE
FOR THE JUSTICDE
CIRCUMSTANCES?
>> SO I WANT TO ASK OTHER THING
TODAY.
A FERAE LATE TAYATS SEEKINLD TRE
NU6th
.
I WANTO IZE CILAWSUITS.
HOW SIGNIFICANT IS TNG, ANNYTHIO
THIS WAS WIG
AL PROVEAND THE SAID THAT TRUMP
EN STATU TO
TE HOLDINGOFFICE, SECT.
SIGNIFICANTLY THE JUDGE DID NOTF
AND DONALD TRUMP JR.
S MES
WILL MOVE FORWARD INTO A
WHAT TRUMPT LIKE IS
NG